bonsoir mello bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
alors ludovic chancel vous êtes le fils
de sheila et vous dis dans le livre que
vous publié chez flammarion
quoi que je fasse quelles que soient mes
efforts pour tenter d'exister par moi
même je suis et je reste le fils de
celle à moins qu'ils ne demandaient rien
d'autre que d'être celui d'annie
chancelle ça résume bien le livre est
bien au revoir
ça résume bien le vivent ouais ça résume
bien le livre c'est un petit peu ça
c'est difficile d'exister face à
l'énorme chela qui prend énormément
d'importance
alors si tu arrives d'une grande
sincérité si parfois même impudiquement
tous les cas très touchant très très
touchant alors on va prendre les choses
par le commencement
alors ça commence le 13 février 1973
dans une église du xiiie arrondissement
quand annie chancel du chellah épouse
guibel votre papa ringo louis l'iccat
deux ans plus tard le 7 avril 1975 vous
naissez ludovic et deux ans plus tard
encore vos parents divorcent
ils vont rester seul avec sheila donc
qui va vous élevez vous dites comme une
fleur de serre c'est à dire complètement
coupé du monde
mais oui on vit en vase huis clos on est
en complète autarcie on est on
c'est comme un clan wesh pas on est sur
moi je suis sûr côté j'ai
personnellement et c'est une vie assez
spécial c'est un peu comme le jeune
budak et qui est protégé avec un joueur
sort comme ça et d'aider et découvre le
monde d'une sur cinq sans ces gens là il
pleut et là c'est le drame
mais c'est là alors celle à l'époque est
cornaqué par un partout de carrère elle
est absorbée par sa réussite
professionnelle
elle préfère l'amour du public
finalement à votre amour elle travaille
elle travaille dur déjà pour pour nous
enfin pour sa famille pour moi mais si
tu veux c'est difficile à expliquer à un
enfant même si je sais qu'elle travaille
pour moi et pour pour les bienfaits de
la vie enfin pour ça c'est beaucoup
c'est dur à expliquer de savoir que sa
mère est adulé par des millions de gens
sains et finalement donne à mon avis à
ce moment là donc il faut se remettre un
peu dans le contexte peu d'importance à
son sens en garde ce sont finalement
elles mais c'est ce que tu penses tu
vois aujourd'hui j'ai 30 ans donc je
vois autrement mais à l'époque c'est moi
ce que je pense à ce moment là ouais
ouais c'est ça il faut se remettre un
petit peu dans le contexte alors sans
doute parce qu elle culpabilise
elle a beaucoup d'attention pour vous
m'élisez la façon qu'ils sont tous deux
matches par exemple dans un hôtel
particulier que vous habitez à l'époque
rue de la ferme
un jour elle achète un sapin pour noël
qui fait trois étages de haut donc à
elle fait pas grand chose mais quand
elle le fait c'est toujours un peu trop
quoi elles comblent pas mal de choses
elles comblent pas mal de choses c'est
normal parce que bon allez souvent
absent donc elle essaie de faire le
maximum quand elle est présente pour que
ce soit facile d'ailleurs j'en garde de
très bons souvenirs mais c'est vrai
qu'on signifie de pallier le manque et
tout mais malgré toutes les attentions
qu'elle peut avoir il ya un moment donné
où il ya un fossé qui se creuse je pense
que c'est ça qu'il faut dire alors c'est
l'époque de spacer elle est souvent un
lien au numéro un par la voilà alors
vous quand vous allez à new york jets
l'an concorde
tant qu'à faire c'est moi ouais vous
passez vous passer l'été à saint-tropez
l'hiver à méribel enfin vous avez une
vie une vie de rêve une vie de jeune
prince
ouais c'est une sorte de prison dorée en
fait on s'aperçoit pas tu vois comment
il le monde à l'extérieur et c'est un
petit peu ça c'est alors jusqu'à l'âge
de 12 ans vous ne savez pas ce que fait
votre maire ludovic et vous allez
découvrir ça un jour aussi découvrir les
dommages collatéraux de la célébrité
lorsque gérard de villiers lance cette
horrible affaire
sheila est un homme dont vous seriez un
enfant adopté ce qu'est ce que ce qui
est terrible c'est très très dur ouais
enfin c'est vraiment un choc mais si tu
veux c'est c'est plus le fait que
j'arrive à la maison et que si tu veux
d'une histoire un peu anodine une
bagarre de récréation
j'en parle à ma mère et ma mère tout de
suite se sont blessés ce je pense je
n'explique comme ça maintenant mais je
pense le fait de s'expliquer vis-à-vis
de moi le fait que ce soit moi qui lui
en parle le premier elle sait pas
comment gérer une blessure qui pour elle
est restée béante mais jusqu'à
maintenant c'est qu'elle est en fait
elle n'est pas du tout sereine elle est
déstabilisée elle est maladroite
je peux comprendre ça ça lui a causé
tellement de dommages
cela fait tellement mal elle en a
tellement souffert elle sonné tellement
j'ai tellement pris plein la gueule
parce qu'on en a pris plein la gueule
elle sait pas comment l'expliquer et
comme ça vient de moi ça prend une
proportion à une dimension auquel on ne
peut pas enfin j'arrive pas à comprendre
alors qu'au lieu de vous calmer à ce
moment là elle se justifie elle vous dit
j'ai une cassette de ton accouchement
que je te montrerai elle vous la donne
cette cassette où elle me la donnes un
peu plus tard me l'a même pas tout de
suite à la zone quant à mon 17e
anniversaire cassette que je n'ai pas
regardé je t'avoue sincèrement elle est
bien moi je l'avais
c'est maladroit parce que finalement
elle en devient presque oui c'est
troublant remplace en fait les gens qui
rient consacre a besoin elle se met dans
une situation où elle a pas besoin de se
justifier
ouais tu vois pour moi c'est clair c'est
ma mère voilà par final on arrête là la
conversation est elle en train d'amener
des preuves alors que c'est pas la peine
en tout cas entre vous vous en parlez
jamais quoi tout ça non c'est tabou
c'est un sujet tellement alors là vous
vivez dans la maison de feucherolles qui
est une espèce de villa hollywoodienne
dans la banlieue vers un château
disneyien 990 m² habitables séjour de
300 mètres carrés
et puis aussi le musée celle à vous
raconter dans votre livre que finalement
quand elle fait le clip de bang bang
elle garde tout à garder costume avec le
décor c'est une espèce de mausolée je
pense qu'elle garde ça pour ça les gens
et c'est un petit peu si tu veux une
espèce de refuge quand elle se sent pas
bien elle a besoin d'avoir tous ces
vestiges un petit peu du passé
elle en a besoin pour son bien donc je
peux comprendre oui alors vous vous êtes
très beau inventer les cheveux longs ou
les yeux vers 9 garçons c'est clair vous
plaisait beaucoup derrière vous plaisait
aux filles vous plaisait aux garçons et
en fait c'est l'époque où vous donnez
votre premier baiser un garçon ouais bah
ouais bon c'est un petit libération
sexuelle c'est mes années hippies si tu
veux voilà bon voilà bon jeu plaît aux
garçons je mets aux filles
pour moi ça jamais été un tabou mais bon
il ya un truc est très étonnant à votre
bouquin c'est que finalement vous dès le
départ vous à vous et votre bisexualité
sait jamais un problème pour message à
l'air en tous les cas mais ça jamais été
un pur penser comme ça des filles aux
garçons sens oui enfin oui ce alors que
toi tu voulais nous en parler
ta blocage encore sur lui si l'affairé
est classée sur non mais c'est vrai que
ça n'a jamais été un tabou mais bon
alors vous découvrez le sexe à cette
époque et vous décidez de quitter le
cocon familial
vous dites à votre mère maman je veux
partir à paris et la réaction de votre
mère qu'elle réagit mon je pense
maladroitement parce que je pense que
c'est pas le fait est une maman mais pas
son fils dehors tu vois mais c'est
plutôt sous l'emprise un petit peu elle
se dit écoute très bien il veut partir
il n'y a pas de souci voilà tu es à
faire voilà ton sac
allez je lui donne trois semaines un
mois dans un mois il revient mais bon
j'ai un caractère on met à la porte donc
voilà on est devant on roule on a vous
avez 17 ans vous vous retrouvez avec 200
balles en poche chez vous vous dites je
viens sans doute de faire la plus grosse
que la wii pour moi c'est horrible bah
ouais c'est une grosse connerie attends
je moi je m'attendais à du soutien je me
suis dit bon c'est pas de souci elle va
me prendre un petit studio il ya pas de
problème elle va me sponsoriser un petit
peu donc y'a pas de soucis mais là je me
retrouve à la porte avec un sac qui pèse
trois tonnes et je suis comme ça avec
les choix
j'ai tous les malheurs du monde sur moi
tout d'un coup mais bon c'est vrai que
c'est spécial et jamais à ce moment là
vous avez l'idée de retourner à
feucherolles mais à tanger des couilles
je vais pas revenir je suis parti je
vais j'avance aussi parce que et puis
quelque part c'est le fait don de plus
de ne pas vivre dans son nom je me dis
ok j'y vais ouais puis voilà et gm
assume et quelque part c'est important
vous commencez l'îlot b que cette
stagiaire chez michel drucker way pour
tous enfants parents salut michel voilà
votre parent qui dit merci à michel
drucker
absolument voilà mais rapidement vous
plonger dans le stupre et la luxure dans
le le stupre et la luxure secret
j'ai pas bien compris oui la nuque sion
nationaux plus c'est le cas le sexe non
c'est vrai heureusement je ne regarde
jamais j'ai 18 ans j'ai envie 2 sur
wayne m'amuser à tanger 18 ans j'arrive
à paris
moi j'ai envie de j'ai envie de m'amuser
j'ai envie de profiter enfin shepherd là
quand même le plus de vous taper tout ce
qui bouge mais à cette époque là quand
même
qu'ils s'appellent tout ce qui bouge
bien même les couples bon j'ai des
expériences voilà c'est sûr mais c'est
par prochain non il n'ya pas ça comme
art proches voilà mais bon ce libertin
voir les étudiants reçus liberté
chèrement très bien je suis pas trop là
le mec vous demande de baisers sa femme
devant lui vous le faites quoi ça normal
c'est pas méchant mais c'est pas nous
c'est pas très méchant ouais c'est pas
méchant comme ça
vrac demande poliment
tout dépend comment on apprécie la
baisse ce matin tu balances à l'otan
s'est dit si goût
rien volé sa main le but est de pénétrer
mon épouse voiture donc à l'époque vous
êtes complètement coupé de votre mère
vous lui écrivait une lettre
pas de réponse et puis au bout de six
mois elle vous répond la lettre est
tellement pas respectueux ce que vous
vous dites mais c'est bien la peine de
me faire attendre mais si tu veux je
pense je pense qu'à elle elle est dans
sa démarche où j'ai décidé de partir et
si tu veux elle n'arrive pas à revenir
en arrière
elle se dit pas un moment donné bon
allez ça fait quand même allez quoi ça
fait huit mois
tant qu'elle reste sur cette base là bon
il écrit tu vois et comme elle me dit
sur la led bon ben voila je pensais pas
que tu aurais dû appeler pourquoi tu as
écrit quelque part que c'est vachement
déstabilisant elle arrive toujours à
renverser le truc et c'est moi qui suit
mais bon c'est son caractère elle est
comme ça on a été meilleurs comme
chanteuse que comme maman encore ma main
je pense qu'être une grande star comme
elle a été une icône c'est ça doit être
difficile mais c'est difficile vu que
c'est arrivé très jeune en plus ouais
donc elle a pas spécialement peut-être
su s'armer pour plus tard messahel
madore comme une maman qui a un fils
unique elle est allée fou de son fils il
n'y a pas de problème mais je pense
qu'elle le montre mal à l'époque vous
rencontrez sylvia qui est la première
fille pour qui vous ressentez vraiment
de l'amour et et dans sa famille
beaucoup de chaleur humaine c'est en
fait à ce moment là c'est la famille de
sylvia qui vient des autres familles
d'accueil sont faites que pour les gens
simples la vie est simple m'ont aidé à
se prendre la tête on a des maisons
est ce que tu veux de l'argent en fait
on cocon familial il a un petit peu
exposées partout même parents divorcés
manger une maman tu qui est comme elle
est avec son caractère et tu t'aperçois
que finalement pour les gens simples n'y
a que l'amour qui contient toujours à
manger sur la table on s'occupe de sa
famille et ça devient tout de suite il
ya plus de poids ouais c'est ça qui est
important c'est une grande découverte
alors vous rencontrez également à
l'époque un dénommé andré je viens à
votre employeur il a une boutique de
mode oil et votre amant ouais des années
ouais ça me équilibré ça mais qui vivent
ça mais qui parce que si tu veux en
trouvant cette personne je découvre
aussi quelques quelqu'un qui est
important et qui à l'image du papa dont
j'ai besoin donc sam équilibre
énormément quelqu'un qui me fait
confiance
quelqu'un qui me donne la possibilité
d'exprimer dans mon travail qui me donne
plein de possibilités et j'ai si tu veux
c'est deux piliers de ma vie et vous
passer de l'un à l'autre
oui oui on peut dire ça comme ça et s'il
ya c'est que vous voyez andré andré
c'est que vous voyez sylvia oui andré
c'est que je vois
sylvia s'il ya des doutes sur une rien
mais c'est pas un ménage à trois si tu
veux savoir l'agression même pas du tout
et là vous avez un terrible accident de
scooter braun au 25 un soir et vous êtes
vraiment détruit fracture ouverte de la
mâchoire les dents exploser la langue
coupée en deux la rate éclatée cette
côte cassée
oui comme à 15 jours voilà un orage
interne marmara d'absolument quinze
jours de coma
un mois et demi deux mois à l'hôpital et
simon 6 8 mois de rééducation intensive
la remontée sera longue a ouais ça a été
dur ça a été vraiment un passage assez
difficile ça c'est dur c'est assez dur
parce que tu sors de l'hôpital je
faisais tout 55 kg à peu près alors j'en
fais 75 d'habitude c'est un peu
difficile sur quand tu dois dans la
glace ben tu vois un fantôme l'espagne
de zombies dont qui il faut merci merci
et il faut et pour moi merci c'est
gentil et il faut et tu vois il faut il
faut remonter à t'as pas le choix donc
on te dit en plus que t'es pas sûr de
retrouver 100% de ses capacités
donc finalement tu dis bah je vais en
bas je vais par yves assange arrivait à
130 l'histoire de m'emmerder tout le
monde donc c'est à vous raconter la
convalescence est à feucherolles les
vacances au aux caraïbes avec sylvia et
et votre maman et là vous décidez de
faire connaissance avec votre père qui
habite à toulouse
il est parti lorsque j'avais deux ans
j'ai dû le voir je sais pas une fois je
m'en rappelle plus quand j'avais six ans
j'ai pas un grand souvenir
et puis je les u23 fois au téléphone et
c'est tout donc j'ai pas eu de fond de
cloche à côté donc je veux avoir situe à
ma propre opinion sur bas sur le
bonhomme quoi alors ce sera jamais un
père mais je me suis peut-être que je
peux trouver un 18 y aller voilà vous
arrivez dans une cité pavillonnaire un
peu un peu défraîchi toulouse un peu
années 60
voyez une vieille dame qui vote depuis
votre grand mère et qu'il appelle et la
voyais arriver un mec on shore temps
marcel en tongs qui vous dit que tu fous
là toi
bref si maxime dit mieux il me dis
[ __ ] tu ressembles à ta mère pourquoi
tu es venu suis même pas sûr que tu sois
mon fils j'ai rien à redire voilà quand
je vois je vois ta mère bref je te fais
tu fais là bon ok bon bah écoute sa
durée à l'échec pas une minute et demie
mais comme vous le dites je crois que je
vais y aller non répond m c'est ce que
vient faire ici tu veux ya des photos un
peu dans le pavillon
puis jeudi mais quand même tu vois il ya
quelques photos de moi donc
ah non mais je suis pas chez moi ici
ouais bon ben je sors je fais dit m et
si tu veux comme je suis pas du tout à
100% à cette époque là je pleure au bout
de dix mètres mais comme un bébé mais
finalement en pleurant espèce de poids
qui s'en va comme ça et je m'aperçois
que finalement les liens du sang malgré
ce qu'on peut dire
bon ben voila je suis tombé sur un mec
qui bat c est mon géniteur il s'appelle
dit on peut dire il s'appelle louis
l'iccat et exprès en fait ce que vous
dites ce qu'il a jamais vraiment aimé
votre mère ah non non ouais ouais pour
moi voilà c'est ça c'était plus un coup
de pub dourdou dont elle qui est
vraiment été meurtri par sa parce
qu'elle était là vous
avoir un enfant avec l'une est amoureuse
de lui bah oui je pense qu'elle s'est
mariée elle a voulu avoir un assez bon
et des photos dans télé 7 jours et un
papier sur lui dans télé 7 jours il ya
des photos il est assez bull par rapport
à moi et les plus beaux maintenant ces
jeux petits blocs lui ces gens si c'est
vrai c'est gentil seulement voilà alors
là vous marier pour faire plaisir à
sylvia en fait au départ je n'ai pas
vraiment envie de vous marier mais quand
elle vous le propose je faisais pas dire
non quoi si tu veux je me rende un petit
peu l'encontre de l'époque moi j'ai
voulu me marier à 20 ans 22 ans donc
j'ai toujours eu des non non j'arrive à
un âge où j'ai 25 ans ou dont je sors
ben plein d'histoires j'ai pas vraiment
la tête à me marier mais je suis dans un
clan elle a toujours été là pour moi
donc j'ai envie de lui faire partager ce
bonheur
j'ai envie qu'elle soit dans leurs
chansons et j'ai envie de faire plaisir
à mes grands-parents gens soient fiers
de moi
et donc je vous dirai pourquoi pas en
avant allons nous marier à l'église
ce qui est terrible c'est que en
l'enterrant vie de garçon vous tombez
sur une nathalie dont vous faites la
connaissance dans les toilettes on peut
dire ouais et c7 nathalie 7 nathalie lui
résume vite les choses mais tu résumes
vite les choses dans le bouquin ouais et
c'est nathalie non ce qui est terrible
c'est que c'est nathalie vous la
reverrai après une fois que vous serez
mariée et elle veut ça et elle vous fera
un enfant dans le dos
ouais ouais bon dos qu'on se voit un
petit peu puis très vite je me dis vas
t'en je suis content viens de me marier
je vais pas commencer à voir une
relation extra conjugale c'est vraiment
stupide donc je mets fins et rapidement
et au bout d'un an et demi j'ai la merde
l'ani qui m'appellent et qui me dit
écoute et félicitations ma fille vient
d'accoucher
ouais très belle petite fille je suis
pas ravi pour elle et vous êtes le papa
pardon est donc là j'ai mon monde ont
joué aux cartes qui fait qu la claque la
clape à faut dire que le mariage
n'arrange rien vous dit en parlant de
sylvia ce mariage a tué notre amour
bref ça arrive sur beaucoup de mariages
je ne suis pas il n'y a pas que moi je
suis pas le seul exemple mais ça arrive
de se marier et puis si on s'est connu à
ces jeunes
donc il ya un moment donné où nos routes
se séparent
parce qu'elle a d'autres envies que moi
j'ai peut-être d'autres envies aussi et
puis voilà ça nous empêche pas qu on
s'est énormément aimé qu'on a vécu une
très belle histoire d'amour
là c'est le début ludovic de votre
descente aux enfers beaucoup de cocaïne
beaucoup c'est petit aussi jusqu'à 20
grammes par semaine c'est beaucoup quand
même en mai 20 g c'était une image
indiqué tôt je pense que 20 grammes
c'est le minimum à m'arrive d'ailleurs
de faire des 72 heures avec 40 g à aimer
c'est au total destruction comme
j'explique dans l'île via un passage où
si tu veux s'il vient s'il vient sans
var parce que je lui dis tout je dis
toute la vérité
et puis bon que j'ai pas là tu vois là
pas trop le choix elle s'en va et je
ferme toutes les portes de 10h arrive je
paye arrive il m'apporte un sachet oui
je rappelle 35 40 g et si tu veux là je
m'enferme j'arrache le téléphone
je commence à mutiler ouais c'est totale
destruction c'est je n'assume pas du
tout le fait que je je je suis un jeune
mère devant on s'aimait pas du tout à ce
moment là non je suis pas prêt du tout
je déteste je veux me détruire le but
c'est totale destruction je veux
m'anéantir il ya là un drogué puis à le
sexe si ce que vous appelez vos nuits
fauves en fait tous les boîtes
échangistes les bacs comme homos le bois
de boulogne
la totale coin la prostitution tu peux
le dire aussi mais c'est pour le fait de
ne pas se regarder dans la glace
moi un moment donné je me dis je vais y
passer parce que vu les quantités de
drogue que je pense je n'ai pas le
courage si tu veux faire la démarche
d'aller acheter un emploi il me met une
balle dans la tête se répète était plus
un mais j'y arrive pas j'ai pas sa
démarche jamais avec les quantités que
je prends je me dis à un moment donné je
vais partir et pour me salir encore plus
au temps de détruire au maximum
et c'est le but voilà maintenant je sais
pas si c'est bien ou pas bien ce que
j'ai vraiment voulu enfin ça va sortir
du bouquin c'est les 30 dernières pages
c'est vraiment cette descente aux enfers
vivre une vraie descente aux enfers tu
vois c'est pas ouais je prends un peu de
drogue où je sors un petit peu on sait
pas trop ce que je fais bon voilà voilà
ce que j'ai fait voilà maintenant bien
ou pas bien c'est pas la question mais
c'est une vraie descente et c'est ce que
je veux expliquer dans votre seule
ambition à ce moment là c'est de vous
salir de vous avez me punir - je veux
plus me regarder dans la glace je veux
voir un cadavre c'est le but
oui c'est le but mais j'y arrive très
bien j'avais vous allez à un moment dans
des boîtes
ils ont deux sexes et vous voulez c'est
posséder par tour mais voilà j'ai envie
de vendre mon âme devant de mon corps
avancent que je suis vivante ce que je
représente vente c'est-à-dire me salir
tout le jeu c'est pas l'honnêteté toute
la la pudeur que j'ai j'ai envie de
lajemmerais j'ai envie j'ai envie de la
détruire c'est dur c'est que cela c'est
un procédé difficile de se dire à un
moment donné quand toi tu décides de te
faire du mal
y a plus de limites si tu veux tu tiens
adversaires vous battez si le silo choc
est violent il ya un moment donné où tu
te mets en retrait parce que dis je vais
pas trop l'année mais là que c'est dans
la démarche que toi tu as envie de te
salir il n'y a plus de limite et c'est
ce que je veux et des adversaires elle
est dans ta tête à tout moment vous
commencez à choisir vos clients sur
internet parce que vous découvrez que
c'est plus facile finalement que la
porte dauphine et là vous tapez jusqu'à
six clients par jour quoi dans un
appartement qui non mais c'est dû à
l'appartement mais dont on sait bien que
c'est un appartement sur des poteaux un
dépotoir
bon c'est un passage bombay j'essaie de
l'expliquer jeu j'espère que ça choquera
pas trop trop de gens j'essaie au monde
qu elle expliqué avec mes mots et je
vais assez sincère
oui c'est sincèrement si c'est touchant
c'est gentil si votre igloo un jeu aussi
est de rentrer dans le détail à ce point
et de tout raconter comme ça
sinon merci belge est en tout cas si
ludovic chancel fils de chez publié chez
flammarion
et là comment ça va vous aimez mieux
maintenant ça commence à venir
ouais ça commence à aller mieux dernière
question
ludovic si vous aviez annie chancel en
face de vous vous lui diriez quoi là là
tout de suite un vrai mais que je laime
murs j'ai pas j'ai pas changer mon
optique depuis le début du livre
j'arrête pas lui dire que je laime c'est
là ma maman c'est la femme de ma vie
et malgré il peut y avoir des erreurs
dans un parcours et c'est pas grave je
n'en veux pas du tout voit sa place je
pense pas que j'aurais pu faire mieux
donc voilà si la femme de votre vie
celle là non je suis là non mais à nice
est la femme de ma c'est sûr
cela n'a rien mais la mise
merci lui de remercier de tout esprit
on peut
pour l'histoire
ouais ouais très émouvant ce bouquin
très étonnant très souvent et il a une
vie surréaliste et quand tu lis ce
bouquin tu es content de le voir
tu es content de voir qu'il va pas si
mal finalement nous faire bien même et
faudra combien suivi quand même info
rappelle enfin qu'en tant qu'on
l'appelle régulièrement quand il y va il
y va il a un peu de suicide et à la gare
sans ouais ouais ouais
est ce un bon gars très d'un bon gars ya
de l'eau mais pas trop et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater le leonard youtube
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu